everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're going to be
going over a famous game between Lasker
and Capablanca and these were two great
world chess champions back in the early
1900's late 1800s last year was the
world champion for actually 27 years
which is quite a long time in capablanca
as many regarded as one of the best
players of all time especially in the
endgame his in-game play over the board
was just magnificent which as we get
deeper into this game that we're going
to analyze today it's kind of
interesting how this game played out as
far as the end game so we'll go ahead
and get into it
Lasker is playing the white pieces and
capablanca is going to be playing people
like pieces and starts out with Pawnee
for Pawnee 5 9 f3 knight c6 and then
Bishop to b5 getting into the ride Lopez
and from here capablanca decides to come
to a6
very common move and Lasker decides to
exchange on c6 now it is very common to
exchange or a lot of times you will see
the bishop come back to a4 and then
retreat back to b3 here attacking the f7
square but in this case Lasker decided
to go ahead and play the exchange
variation and he plays Bishop takes on
c6 and black recaptures with his pawn
opening up this D file for his Queen
here now from here white decided to
bring his pawn to d4 keep in mind that
is very common now for white to castle
on the King side but Lasker played d4
signifying that he's ready to get into
the in game very quickly he doesn't want
there to be a long middle game which is
surprising considering his opponent is
such a strong endgame player but Lasker
must have felt pretty confident going
into this and played d4
after black captured here on d4 then
white decided to come up and recapture
with his queen on d4 again signifying he
wants to get these Queens off the board
he wants to
advanced very quickly into the in game
there's not going to be a very long
middle game going here after both sides
castle both sides are really going to
try to get active get their kings
activated and then start going for an
endgame from here Capablanca bludge dand
took with his queen on d4 getting ready
to go into the end game and white
recapture with his knight on d4 now
black had two options here he probably
could have had more than that but the
most typical move from here from black
would be to bring his Bishop to d7 as
far as just opening principles and
theory behind the opening since this
night from b8 is already gone and this
Queen is no longer taking this d8 Square
getting your light squared Bishop from
black into the game and at the same time
allowing your King to castle on the
Queen side with this rook nicely placed
on the opened e-file
you can obviously cast your King much
faster than you can on the King side so
keep this in mind in the game Capablanca
went ahead and played Bishop to d6 but
again Capablanca will have to play
another move get his knight here from g8
also into the game before he can cast it
but it looks like he wants to castle on
the King set but if you come to this
position in your own game you can see
that Bishop to d7 is not only an okay
move but it may be preferred because of
opening principles that we just talked
about so in this game we play continued
with Bishop to d6 and now Knight
continues to develop to c3 from white
and black now brings his knight to e7
both sides getting right into Castle
white castles and black castles now so
far in the game nothing crazy has
happened both sides have just been
developing all their pieces from here
white can bring his dark squared Bishop
into the game if he wants to connecting
the rooks you always want to connect
your rooks as far as opening principles
same with black here he can develop his
LightSquared Bishop get that into the
game at the same time he will connect
his rooks along this eighth rank as well
from here Lasker decided to go on to the
attack and he played pawn to f4 his King
is a little bit in danger but since the
Queens are off the board his King is a
little less in danger than it would be
before if let's say the Queen's were not
traded off you know this would be a
little less safe of a king than it is
now but Lasker decided to go ahead and
continue up the board with pawn to f4
and black played rook to e8 getting his
rook on this semi open file but another
move that black could have played is
bringing his Bishop to c5 pinning this
knight down to the King it doesn't
matter who you are you really don't want
to be playing with your pieces pinned
down especially to your King just
because it's another thing that you have
to worry about and you really don't want
to have a lot of different weaknesses in
a chess game because the more weaknesses
you have the better chance your opponent
has to exploit those weaknesses but
capablanca decided not to do this and
decided instead to bring his rook to e8
which seems logical you know you want to
get your rooks involved and he has this
semi open file along the e-file here so
far white now is going to bring his
Knight to b3 one he does not want to
give his knight pin down to the king so
that's something to think about
after Lasker saw this he obviously
wanted to bring his pawn to f4 but at
the same time he doesn't want to have to
worry about this Knight being pinned
down the entire game so from here black
played pawn to f6 and it's a very
interesting move if you think about what
all black wants to do in this game he
really does not want white to control
the center of the board white played
this pawn to f4 because it really wants
to control the center right away and so
black is trying to in essence control
this e5 square right away it's a very
important square and since white has
already played pawn to f4 black
capablanca is really trying to put a lot
of pressure on this e5 square trying not
to give it up right away now the next
move from white was a very important
move as far as what his goal was in the
game so if you just pause it and think
about what white should do in this
situation and if you think about all the
different options that white has one of
his best ones is to bring his pawn to f5
which is what he did in the game a lot
of beginner players will say you know
what
before I do anything in a chess game I
need to develop all my pieces connect my
rooks and then continue with the game
but if you look at this lasker can
already tell right away
you know if I bring my pawn to f5 since
his pawn already here on f6
then I'm pretty much in essence blocking
off this lights for Bishop from black
he's not going to bring it to you know
to d7 that's not doing anything he can't
bring it to e6 he's going to have to
bring it to b7 if he wants to get
involved but to do that he's going to
have to move this pawn from b7 and this
pawn from c6 so this pawn here on f5
even before he develops his dark square
Bishop is really limiting the squares
that black can play his lights for a
bishop so anytime even before you
develop all your pieces and connect your
rooks and get your King involved in the
endgame you really want to look at what
your opponent's doing and see if you can
block off some of his potential moves
down the road if you can limit some of
the pieces that he can get involved
that's usually a good thing from here
capablanca decided to bring his pawn to
b6 again now that his LightSquared
bishop socked off on this diagonal he
really needs to find a way to get it
involved somewhere else so he's getting
ready to bring his bishop to b7 it's
going to take a few moves but he does
obviously want to get this involved now
from here white decided to bring his
bishop to f4 right away his dark square
bishop a lot of times from white this
dark square bishop isn't doing too much
so he decides to go ahead and bring it
to f4 and at the same time he's really
threatening putting this pawn here on d6
now as someone may have you know told me
a long time ago at the beginning of the
game you always want to control the
center of the board with your pawns at
the end of the game you want to control
the center of the board with your pieces
and not your pawns you'd rather have
your pieces in the middle and your pawns
on the outside if your pawns are in the
middle it's very easy for your opponent
with any of his pieces to control those
pawns if you have pawns on both sides of
the board it's very hard for him to
attack or control both sides or both
pawn structures that you have so why it
is playing you know obviously he's
developing his
Bishop to f4 but at the same time he's
challenging he's saying I'm gonna on you
know undal your pawns here but at the
same time I'm going to give you a pawn
here on d6 if he recaptures it's going
to be very hard for you to hold on to
later in the game so that's kind of why
this was was played out from here
white decided excuse me black besides it
plays Bishop to b7 a lot of scholars and
analysts you know decided that
capablanca just didn't think that Lasker
would undeveloped these pawns here but
that's exactly what Lasker did he went
ahead and captured on d6 and black
recaptures with this pawn on d6 so right
away you can see here that this pawn
here on d6 there's going to be a huge
thorn for black he tries to control you
know this pawn here in the middle of the
board and pretty much all the pieces
that White has are going to be just
aiming for this d6 pawn for a while so
if we look at now it's White's play
again and white just played an amazing
game so I really want you to pause and
think about what white strategy strategy
should be now and hopefully you see that
this square here on e6 is a great
outpost especially for a knight so in
White's mind his plan right away
he's already developed his pieces he
already has his rooks connected he can
get those involved into the game
whenever he wants to but he really wants
to get a night here on e6 it's going to
be a very powerful piece and right away
there's nothing that black can do you
know to take that away if he wants to
bring his bishop back to c8 he can but
again blacks wasting moves here if he
brings his bishop to b7 and then back to
ca to challenge this night here on e6 so
that's exactly what Lasker does he
brings his knight back to d4 so that he
can places nice his knight nicely on
this e 6 Square from here black decided
to bring his rook to d8 and this has
been a very criticized move by many
analysts they really think that black
should have played Bishop to c8 pretty
much putting your ego aside and saying
you know what I made a mistake I
shouldn't have played my bishop to b7 in
the first place I should
kept it here on c8 because this rook
here on d8 is not stopping this night
and at the same time this knifes not
going to be kicked off for a while and
it's going to be a very vital square for
white to control here with this night
so black decided to play rook to d8
trying to put a little bit more pressure
on this pawn to d6 that we talked about
was already a weakness for black and
white continues with his plan bringing
his knight to e6 so right away
white right away has a very strong
attack he has you know this night here
on e6 attacking this rook I'll see the
rooks going to come to d7 there's no
reason for him to retreat back why would
he have come to the eight in the first
place so he comes to d7 and now white
starts to get his rooks involved he
brings his rook to d1 and now black here
brings his Knight to c8 he obviously
wants to try to add a little bit more
pressure to this d6 square again it is a
huge weakness for black from here
White's going to bring his rook to f2
probably thinking that he wants to you
know next bring it to d2 whenever he
wants to and start to again add more and
more pressure to this d6 quick from here
black played pawn to b5 now this is
probably a questionable move because you
really want black really wants to get
his LightSquared bishop into the game it
probably would have made a little bit
more sense if you try to move like a six
and then he could have brought his
bishop or excuse me his pawn to a5 and
then he could have brought his Bishop to
a6 could have brought it down the c-4
and then he could have challenged this
night here on e6 that we talked about is
very strong capablanca didn't see it
that way instead he decided to bring his
pawn to b5 this is a very important move
from white white decided to bring his
rook to d2 first and then after the rook
comes to e7 white decided to bring his
pawn to b4 now if you look at this right
away white even though this pawn is
unprotected he's basically trying to
lock in this pawn structure that black
has along these you know white squares
here now when you approach the
in game your Bishop you really don't
want to have it on the same colored
square so right away Capablanca has this
light square bishop and his pawns here
are blocking it in you want to be
attacking your opponent's pawns and not
be blocked in by your own so right now
this move b4 it looks kind of harmless
but it's the same way it locks in this
pawn structure which really limits what
black can do here with his light square
bishop so from here black starts to get
his King into the game now that we've
kind of approached the in game or the
starting stages of the endgame you
always want to start to centralize your
King do the very very strong attacker in
the endgame White's going to continue to
bring his pawn to a3 putting another
supporter on this b4 pawn now black
plays Bishop to a8 here and this has
also been criticized as a poor move from
capablanca when capablanca went back and
looked at this game he actually said
that if he would have played rook to e6
and after you know the pawn takes and he
were to retake with his rook that he
could actually have drawn this game but
at the time he said that he was all over
the board and trying to find different
ways to counter and he just decided to
play Bishop to a8 because he did not
want to go ahead and play rook takes on
e6 but looking back he said that was
probably the smart move this really
doesn't do much for you know blacks
development he's kind of just waiting
for white to attack
so from here white decides to start to
get his King involved into the game and
now black plays rook to a7 and this is
probably because he wants to have some
counter play on the Queen side he's
probably going to look to play his pawn
to a5 try to open up this a file so he
can get his rook into the game by this
once he opened up this a file get his
rook into the game if he wants to you
know he can play this pawn down to c5
get his LightSquared Bishop into the
game maybe he wants to swing his other
rook into the action once is you know
bishops no longer here on a8 so
Capablanca really is trying to have some
counter play into the game by playing
that white continues with pawn to g4
again now that all of his pieces are
really developed and they're exactly
where they need to be he's really going
to start to try to attack on the
kingside he sees that blacks trying to
you know attack on the Queen set here so
since all his pieces are centralized and
they can get to anywhere on the board
he's going to go ahead and start to
attack on the King set and so blacks
going to try to limit some of the
pressure that White's putting on here by
playing pawn to h6 and now White's going
to play rook to d3 really allowing this
rook to get into the game on the King
side if he needs to it's a little bit
limited if he is on the D 2 square but
bringing it to the d3 square it allows
him if he needs to to swing over to h3
or if he starts to push up push up this
H pawn he can always swing his rook over
there he's not blocked off by this King
here on f2 from here black is going to
continue with his plane that we talked
about bringing his pawn to a5 and
White's going to disregard this there's
no reason to take on here it's basically
just giving up a move and then you have
this pawn on a3 hanging here so he's
going to continue to tack on the King
side after black captures white
recaptures on b4 and then a very
interesting move that it again is being
criticized for a long time against kappa
blanka he moves his rook back to e7 and
this is questionable because he opened
this a file up probably so he can have
some counter play you know on this Queen
side but he brought his rook here from
e7 over to a7 and now has brought it
back to e 7 so it looks like Capablanca
is coming up with a plan trying to
execute that and then the last minute is
just retreating and isn't quite sure
what he wants to do here now from here
Lasker just decided to continue with his
plan he played King to f3 trying to get
his King involved into the game again
more centralized that you can get your
king and the endgame is always good and
black decided to bring his rook to g8
knowing that the King side is going to
be attacked so he wants to get his
pieces involved if you need them there
and white plays King to f4 again
continuing what we talked about getting
your King involved his other pieces are
again nicely placed just waiting for the
opportunity to arise where they may be
needed and black is going to play pawn
to g6 just trying to counter play a
little bit opening up this G file if he
needs to again really trying to find
some counter play because as you can see
right now blacks been pretty passive as
far as his defenses he's just kind of
been roaming around moving his pieces
back and forth and so he's trying to
open up the game here any way you can
from here why decided to bring his rook
to g3 again solidifying putting a little
bit more pressure on the King side you
always want to have rooks behind your
pieces that they push up the board
especially your pawns and from here
black decided to try to close this off a
little bit if he could and bring his
pawn to g5 white would have really liked
to play as pawn to g5 if he could have
but black kind of beat them to the punch
and play pawn to g5 here so the king is
going to retreat back a little bit
bringing his King back to f3 and then
the Knights going to try to get involved
into the action and he kind of leaves
his pawn hanging here
if white wanted to take on d6 but you
always got to keep in mind you know a
lot of times if you're playing a weak
player they may actually leave you know
this pawn for you to take if you're
pulling a player like Capablanca who's
one of the strongest players of all time
he's not going to bring his knight here
to b6 just so lasker can come in and
take extra material and kind of dominate
the middle of the board so if we look at
this here and if white were to take on
d6 then you know Capablanca could bring
his knight down to C for attacking this
rook here on d6 after the rook moves
then the knight can come to e5 and this
is again a great square much like this
east six square is a great square for
the knight this he 5 square is a great
square for black hair and yes black did
give up a pawn but at the same time
black now has a lot of counter play he
has a very centralized knight that's
attacking you know he can bring his
rooks into the action on the D file and
at the same time this night here on e5
is going to be a
thorn and Whiteside the entire game so
thankfully for Lasker he decided to
avoid this and realize that he didn't
need to take this pawn on d6 it's going
to be a huge weakness as we talked about
all game it's going to be hard for black
to defend this pawn so he decides to
completely disregard this and continue
with his plan his playing is right now
to attack on the kingside so he's going
to take with his pawn on g5 and after
black recaptures on g5 then he's going
to bring his rook to h3 trying to attack
this open file you always want your
rooks on open files so white right away
is going to bring his rook to h3 along
this open file black from here responded
with his rook to d7 again he doesn't
want to leave this pawn hanging too much
obviously he brought his knight to b6
here he did leave it hanging doesn't
want to leave it hanging too long here
so it does bring his rook back to d7
white decided to bring his king to g3 as
you can tell this light square bishop
it's not into the game yet but down the
road it could be so white really wants
to get his King off this long white
diagonal just in case you know this pawn
were to move up you know at any time you
know this pawn if he comes down to c5
would open up the door for a discovered
attack on the King here so it really
wants to avoid that from here black
decided to bring his King to e8 and now
a masterful move from white here he
brings his rook to h1 it's really
starting to put a lot of pressure on
black and there's not a whole lot that
black can do here as far as counter play
black decides to bring his Bishop to b7
as you can see there's just not a lot of
good moves that black has here and then
white plays pretty much the crucial move
in the entire game and that's pawn to e5
if you want to take a minute just to
look at the situation and think about
what pawn to e5 does it's a magnificent
move than it does so much and one of the
really important things that it does is
it allows this knight here to come to e4
and once this knight comes to e4 it's
just going to be a huge
born in black side and there's not going
to be much black and do you know to
really stop the attack that white has
here once he can pretty much centralized
both his nights you know up the board
it's really going to be hard for black
to stop this attack his King pretty much
is safe over here on the g3 square so
he's pretty much playing e5 to get his
other Knight into the game and then just
hard to attack an attack an attack from
here black took with his pawn on e5
opening up this pup this D file for his
rook if he does need it trying to get
some counter play but it is probably a
little too late the Knights going to
come to leaf or trying to get some you
know obviously some power in the center
of the board here he is attacking this
pawn here on f6 which is a huge you know
threat you know attacking not only the
King but both of the rooks here the
knight from black is going to come to d5
obviously he wants to get his knight
involved in the game but at the same
time he really does need to defend this
pawn here on f6 because it is a huge
weakness for black here and from here
why it's going to bring his knight to c5
and this is probably what Lasker saw all
along and this is a huge move because
he's going to be able to take this rook
here on d8 or excuse me on d7 the bishop
is kind of forced to bring you know to
come here on C and you look at any like
you know Kevin he's just going to leave
you know his rook hanging but you know
if he brings his rook to d6 you know or
d8 then Y can come in and take a free
bishop here on b7 that's not really what
you want to do in the same fashion if
black were to bring his rook anywhere
along the seventh rank then white could
swoop in here you know attack the King
here and at the same time forking this
Bishop on b7 there's now two attackers
on this Bishop on b7 and it's going to
be a free bishop or white here so black
pretty much is forced to play in this
situation
Bishop to c8 and then from here white
can win this exchange and play his
Knight captures on d7 and after the
Bishop recaptures then why it's going to
start to you know really get the rest of
his pieces involved into the game now
you've probably heard a lot of people
talk about
the endgame which we are in now
obviously you really want to get your
rooks on to the second or the seventh
rank a lot of people say the second rank
but the seventh rank obviously is the
same thing they're just very dangerous
this King is not going anywhere this
rook is pretty much going to wreak havoc
the entire time that he's back here
so from here blacks going to play rook
to f8 just trying to someway solidify
some sort of defense you know against
White's attack here again he wants to
try to add a little bit more pressure to
this f6 square if he ever does want to
move his knight here then this pawn here
on f6 is going to be hanging and night
this night here can swoop in anytime he
wants to and that's not going to be good
for for black so he brings his rook here
to f8 and now white brings his rook to
a1 again he's already attacking this
h-file and now he's going to bring his
rook on a1 over to the a file and start
to attack on the opposite side it's
really hard to defend on two sides of
the board which we talked about before
if you have one weakness you can maybe
defend that but if you have more than
one weakness it's really hard to defend
here so blacks going to play his King to
d8 trying to get some sort of safety
here and now the rooks going to come to
a a attacking this King here on d8 and
there's not much the black can do he
brings his bishop to c8 and the knight
comes to c5 and from here it is pretty
much good game now play could continue
you know after the the knight comes to
b6 here then the knight could come to b7
and we could start to attack in you
obviously you can't take with his bishop
he can kick back his King to e8 this is
again not what happened in the game but
one of the you know continuations that
we may have seen you know it could now
bring his Knight to d6 you know
attacking the King just really getting
all his pieces into the game where they
need to be and then after the King comes
back to b8 his only legal move then the
rook can come to b8 and there's nothing
what black can do except lose this piece
here on b6 and this is if black played
you know the best moves possible
obviously and the game
kappa blanka decided just to resign but
in this situation if they if the knight
moves here from b6 he's going to lose
the game it's going to be checkmate in
one but if he doesn't move his knight
then he's going to lose a knight and is
going to be even down you know more
material in the game so as most you know
high-level World Chess Champion games
are played once a situation is lost you
pretty much just resigned and that's
what capablanca did in this situation so
as you can see here Lasker had a
specific plan he continued with that
plan he executed it very well capablanca
was kind of all over the board so keep
that in mind in your own game
you know even a fantastic player like
capablanca if you kind of deviate from
your plan back-and-forth and you just
kind of play back and just let your
opponent attack attack and you don't
have any sort of counter play and you're
not really doing anything active with
your pieces more than likely you're
going to lose the game so hopefully you
guys enjoy this video if you haven't
already please subscribe and I'll see
y'all in the next video thanks for
watching